معنا من خان يونس مراسلنا اسماعيل ابو عمر
اسماعيل تطورات كثيره في خان يونس لو تجمل
لنا المشهد
لديك نعم بيانات كتاب القسام وكذلك
المقاومه الفلسطينيه مستمره في الصدور بين
الحين والاخر بعد اشتباكات ضاريه نفذتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مناطق ومحاور
القتال المختلفه في المحافظات كان اخر هذه
البيانات ما اعنت عن كتاب القسام قبل قليل
باطلاق قذيفه مضاده للتحصينات باتجاه قوه
اسرائيليه كانت قد تحصنت داخل احد المنازل
ومن ثم اتبعت هذه القذيفه بقذيفه اخرى
وحسب البيان فان صراخ الجنود تم استماع له
بشكل واضح في تلك المنطقه بعد عمليه
الاستهداف التي تمت في منطقه بلوك جي من
مخيم خان يونس لكن هذا البلاغ قد يكون في
اوقات سابقه نتحدث عن صباح هذا اليوم كان
هناك اشتباكات في منطقه الحاووز منذ صباح
هذا اليوم وقد نتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه
او الدقائق القادم ان يكون بيانات اخرى
جديده لكتاب القسام او للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه سراي القدس وغيرها ب لتبني بعض
العمليات التي تمت خلال صباح هذا اليوم من
اشتباكات من نقاط قرمه قريبه ما بين قوات
الاحتلال وكذلك المقاومه الفلسطينيه نتحدث
بان الاشتباكات تركزت في هاتين المنطقتين
كذلك منطقه حي الامل وهي محور قتال رئيسي
لقوات الاحتلال وهناك اشتباكات تدور بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك قوات الاحتلال
في ظل هذه الاشتباكات عمليات القصف
المدفعي لا تتوقف من قبل مدفعيه الاحتلال
في كافه محاور القتال وكذلك في المناطق
التي تعد هادئه نسبيا في المناطق الشرقيه
لمحافظه خانيونس يتم قصف هذه المناطق من
قبل مدفعيه الاحتلال اضافه الى عمليات نصف
تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال بين الحين والاخر
لمربعات سكنيه ومنشات صناعيه في اكثر من
منطقه من محافظه خانيونس كذلك عمليات قصف
من الجو تقوم بها طائرات احتلال لا لاهداف
عديده في محافظه خنوس نتحدث منذ صباح هذا
اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظه تم انتشال اربعه
شهداء من منطقه جورت اللوت وكذلك المناطق
الشرقيه للمحافظه تم وصول ه هؤلاء الشهداء
الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي اضافه الى ارتقاء
شهيده وهي الفتاه رؤى رؤى اقديح تم
اعدامها رميا بالرصاص من قبل قناصه
الاحتلال بينما كانت تحاول الوصول الى
مستشفى ناصر خاصه ان نتحدث بان هناك تجمع
للمدارس حول هذا المستشفى وتعيش هذه
المدارس والنازحين داخل هذه المدارس اوضاع
انسانيه وكارثه خاصه في في ظل عدم توفر
المياه والغذاء لهؤلاء المواطنين ف
يحاولون الوصول للمستشفى لتوصيل امدادات
المياه الى النازحين داخل هذه المدارس
تحدثنا قبل قليل مع احد شهود العيان في
تلك المنطقه قالوا بانهم ي يقومون بعمليات
امداد للمياه عبر عقد احبال بقالو المياه
و وتوصيلها من المستشفى الى المدارس في ظل
استمرار اطلاق النار من قبل اليات
الاحتلال وال المتمركزه بالقرب مزد بلال
ومنطقه الحاووز تقوم باطلاق النبض جاه كل
من يتحرك في هذا الشارع الذي يعد شارعا
حيويا ويتحرك فيه كثير من النازحين
اسماعيل ابو عمر من خانيونس شكرا جزيلا لك